Optimization philosophy is something
we want to cover because optimization isn't something
that should be done at one stage or another stage
of your project, but something that
should be done at every stage.
Whenever your project is starting,
whenever your project is in the middle,
and even until the end of your project,
optimization is an ongoing effort.
Optimizing your Unreal Engine 5 project
is also going to be the result of many small optimizations.
There will be no one single optimization
that will help any poorly performing project run better.
Because of this, you need to ensure
that you're checking your project's optimization using
the techniques in this tutorial series
at every stage of your project.
This will ensure that if there are any performance issues,
they can quickly be addressed and rectified
and your project will ship on time with the features
you intended to use and look exactly like you want it.